and the winner is
[Music]
first of all we have a double
congratulations in order
winner of the circle plus you're
expecting
yes right here big old belly
how far along are you um oh i'm horrible
at counting
but i'm due in a month and a half oh my
gosh
okay so when did you find out were you
filming the circle
yeah so i found out while i was in the
apartment
um you know when you're a woman you just
know
your body so like i was getting all the
symptoms that i was getting when i was
pregnant with my daughter
and um i just kept trying to like push
it back and then i just mentioned this
to the producer i'm like you know one of
the producers i was like you know i
think i'm like
pregnant and they're like oh do you want
to take a test i'm like
no so they asked me a few times and i
actually i kept saying no but
after a while i feel like um i just got
the sense that it was like
a health reason that they wanted to make
sure that i was okay
um so i wound up taking a test i found
out i was pregnant and
i held on to that i didn't tell him so
you didn't know
no no i had no clue at all so you win
you get home and then you tell well i
told him at the finale they didn't they
didn't show it but
i wound up telling him oh when we were
on the facetime oh my gosh
major bombshell like like my bro my mind
was completely blown
at that point i'm coming home with a
hundred thousand dollars and a baby yeah
yeah how has it been you you won the
show also so how has it been watching it
back
have you watched all the episodes back
at this point oh definitely
for sure definitely watch the back cry
the tears again
my heart was pounding again i just
basically relived the moment
it was um it was incredible to watch me
in that experience and then also know
what the rest of the cast was thinking
and doing at the same time that i was
talking to them
um it's just so funny and nostalgic and
trevor what's it like for you watching
delisa be you on the show it was
definitely weird one because they keep
calling her trevor obviously
uh you know so i'm sitting there
watching it and i'm like it was just
it's really bizarre to
see my face have her portray portray me
and not actually be there so it was
definitely a little weird for me but i
think she did a great job
uh you know there was a couple times
where i was just like oh babe no
no no no no no even though you know the
end result
i didn't change the fact that you got to
sit there and watch every single episode
and go through it so all that
all the stress and and things that other
people felt i felt as well even though i
knew
didn't really matter yeah what was your
babe no no no no moment
uh the big one was the mannequin
challenge that i was like
oh you gotta throw this like this how
you have to just mail this in
like they're gonna know you're oh you're
not a guy if you do this too well and i
know how my work my wife feels about
makeup
so i was like she's gonna be super
excited to do this this is not gonna go
well and
she she's so good at it that she did she
tried to do a bad job and it still came
out good
thank goodness for jack aka emily in
that challenge because all the attention
went to that
absolutely um trevor i have to know how
you feel about
um the fact that you both are dating
chloe
that's our girlfriend
yeah apparently she's just she's been
welcomed into this marriage
completely unbeknownst to me but you
know it's um
again really bizarre to see you know my
wife flirt as
a guy um but you know what she did what
she had to do and i mean like
you know she was she was drinking the
sauce so again like that's cool
right kudos to her gameplay because i
was like i really hope she does not have
to flirt
as a guy um but you pulled it off i'm
proud of you good job
thank you chloe wasn't as heartbroken as
people may think
yeah yeah because a lot of people think
that chloe is so
upset like that she fell in love with
trevor and stuff like that and
you know she's we're definitely friends
video chat yesterday um we video chat so
we
talk all the time um when we can because
she's far away
um and we're definitely gonna have her
meet him one day
can't wait for that that's not awkward
at all
i feel like i might be the most
uncomfortable out of the three probably
at this point that would maybe chloe
would be you think so
i don't know i don't know that'd be
interesting
and he chatted with mitchell so like
that's pretty cool too
they have this whole bromance thing
going on i love the guy adorable
the blessing and the curse of winning is
you have to be away the longest
how long were you away from from home
and how difficult was that
um it was a long time um any i feel like
it was like four to six weeks probably
somewhere in the middle for sure um
it was very difficult you know in the
beginning i'm not gonna lie
like you know i'm a mom 24 7 and i was
with my daughter
every day all day um and it felt really
cool to get like a little break
you know like i'm like oh silence
so um that was fun but then after a
while obviously like i
really miss my daughter i really miss
him um
you know i had that pillow so like i
would hug it and you know sometimes i
would cry at night
i'm happy they didn't show that because
dang i cried so many times on
that show but um yeah it was very
difficult
i'm not gonna lie it was it was pretty
hard um but
it gave me the motivation to do what i
had to do
and work very hard for it and trevor
what was that like for you
having her away you know like when she
first left
i was petrified you know like we dropped
off the airport and i looked at my
daughter and i was like all right kid
it's me and you for the foreseeable
future um and you know
elise was home with her every single day
you know since the day she was born
uh so i was like man it's all me like if
something goes wrong that's on me
uh but you know what it was really cool
because it gave my daughter not time to
bond
something we never would have naturally
had had lisa been there
so i think our relationship in that
point in time was like
it was exactly what we needed so i'm
fortunate for it i mean i missed delisa
every single day i know tony missed her
but it was it was really cool to get to
spend so much
a long time with tony because it would
have i think in
a normal world would never happen do you
still have the pillow
yeah do you want to see it yeah actually
yeah
i actually like cuddle with it at night
it was so cute just like every time she
was like
sitting on the couch just like hugging
the pillow oh my god i love it
i will say it i haven't i mean i watched
last season this season i've never cried
watching the circle until i was watching
like that finale episode i was just like
i'm getting so many comments about that
people were sending me
videos of themselves with like tears
like coming down their face
people were cheering for me like i've
never i mean
i don't know i've never seen that type
of excitement on like any other show
so it just it was an incredible feeling
like watching those videos back i'm like
wow people really
like resonated with my story you know
what i mean
like and it's real it's not like it's
fake it's this is who i am this is who
we are like as a family we needed it
and we got it and um people really
connected to that
and much more than i thought that they
would yeah because i mean i think it's
so hard when people catfish a lot of
times they're like trying to literally
be another person
and i felt like you were just you you
just kind of had to like
malify yourself a little bit absolutely
absolutely and i got um
actually a lot of people still are mad
at the fact that i was a catfish and
it's like
it's game like come on get over it i did
what i had to do
i still can't imagine going in as myself
and a lot of people
they say that to me they're like no you
would i wish you would have went in
as yourself like you definitely would
have made it to the end and i
i don't agree with that i still don't
agree with that i don't think so
trevor how did you feel when de lisa
said i'm gonna catfish as you
that was a great idea fantastic idea
selfishly i'm like this is perfect
i mean like who doesn't want their their
face out there but in the bigger picture
i thought it'd be really smart in the
sense that you know it's tough
as a woman you know what like it can be
really cutthroat
uh the game works very differently for
for males and females so
um you know i thought like it's it's a
really really good strategy
for her to go in as me i think you know
i can be seen as
not so much of a threat i'm like that
nice guy basically exactly what she
portrayed me to be was how i was hoping
i'd be received
i mean don't get me wrong i think my
wife did a fantastic job but i can most
definitely do better like we are we're
the we're
two of the most competitive people that
you ever want to meet
uh so i mean we'll find anything around
the house to compete over uh so
this is just fitting like i i most
definitely think i was really critical
for a game
i'm pretty positive i can do an even
better job he's really nice in public
but behind the scenes he's just like why
would you say that why did you do this
like you've never heard me say that yeah
um and it's all it's all fun and love
obviously um but yeah he thinks he can
do a better job
i know i can do a better job but we all
know the truth you know
i mean you have the title so thank you
thank you for now
you talked about what you were gonna do
with the money on the show but now
now you have you know an unexpected
visitor so
has has the plan changed what are you
doing with the money no um
we we use it for a down payment we're in
our house right now
really for sure um the only thing that
changed was that chanel bag that i'm
probably never gonna get
yeah um i just i feel like we're adults
now and like
there's more important things to life
than material things like
chanel bag or red bottoms and all of
that stuff
yeah definitely so um put some money
away
and um that's this is all about our
family now
that's it trevor the look on your face
is telling me you're getting her the
chanel bag though
are you never know shh it's like in a
couple days
then i have to do it you have to do it
like you have to do it
like but there's like you know we got
there's like a lot of occasions
just yeah you need that what is it the
baby moon gift or the what's it called
push present yeah you didn't give me one
last time i
have to get two we were broke
we had together as a family like even
now
it's just such an amazing experience um
we feel really blessed and grateful
and thank you to everybody who um
took care of us and take taking care of
us right now
um still because the love is still there
netflix is showing so much love um
it's just amazing it's just a crazy
journey and
it is it's a really surreal experience
you know and
one i'm ever grateful for let's plug the
stuff where if people want to see more
stuff from you where where can we find
you
absolutely people are super invested in
our family which i mean
it's seoul shopping tracking because
it's just our regular life yeah
playing live yeah um we have youtube so
the saints family on youtube
um we have videos going back to 2017 i
think oh 2018
yeah before we got married that whole
process of getting married our labor and
delivery
pranks and vlogs and just like us being
like you name it parents and having fun
with each other um and you can find us
on instagram
at least unique grab st prep underscore
saint
and uh we also have a family page uh
it's the saints and our little girls on
instagram too because
you know we have to make her a star as
well it's a
tony hello and i dot a bella
a b e l l a and of course that page is
solely dedicated to her because um you
know i want her to grow up and look back
on
these videos and pictures like wow like
this is my life
exactly i don't have do you have like a
video no yeah i don't really have
well it's a different world now like
that she's gonna be able to look back
and be like
oh look how much fun i have with my
parents and like oh i'm just so excited
for that and for other people to be able
to watch her grow
you know i think it's pretty cool yeah
well yeah definitely
um for sure i mean i'm a mompreneur i'm
working hard i have a lot of things
please not stop working no no seriously
like i probably get
as a pregnant woman how many hours a
week do i get like five
yeah five six yeah five six um i'm sure
all right woman's online boutique the
unique shop shopee.com
like we're gonna see you on like shark
tank next season oh
maybe maybe i have a lot of things going
on
um and i don't plan on stopping and
hopefully um
you know people really like us and maybe
one day you never know
you'll see us on your screen again
but but my main focus is really like
creating generational wealth for
our daughters and um just family members
to come and just making sure like
we're we're good we're comfortable with
stable so that nobody
ever has to be in the position that we
[Music]
felt